Okay, we're
back.
Hi. I'm pretty tired at the moment. I'm
just going to hang out here for an hour,
run some experiments, maybe get a sweep
or two going. Nothing major.
Let's go see the
uh current
experiments. Not these. Not
these. Uh I don't know where I put them.
Oh, no big deal. Oh, here they
are.
training. So, I just noticed that I had
screwed up the hypers.
when I uh I copied some stuff over. So,
it's possible this does work out of the
box. It is
possible. Question is going to be
whether this gets stuck where the
previous one got
stuck. Currently, this has a nice steep
curve on it.
But yeah, other than that, just chill
out, have myself a
shake, and uh see if I can figure out a
few small just small things with these
experiments, you know, so we can get
some good stuff running
overnight. I would much prefer to not
have to run a sweep at this point. Just
run like one really good long PSGD
experiment.
So, I'm going to just do a couple like
little ablations on stuff and see uh see
what I can come up
And these were the params I ran
um ran the other one
with. So you would think it would be
able to optimize on
this. To be fair, this is where the
other one
first started to get
stuck. So we will see whether it keeps
this sort of a curve or
not. I'm trying to think what would be
the
here. Oh, you know what?
Hang on a
second. So when I ran this
before, what's the overall progress
today on neural MMO in general? In
general,
PSGD looks very very good. We did some
more optimizer
stuff. There was some like theoretical
progress today as
well. I mean, in theory, there was
progress. Um, but PSPD looks very
promising, but it's going to depend on
how it does on neural MMO. And there's
some stuff that we have to fiddle with
for
that. If not, we just go back to Muan
and Muan's, you know, we just take our
win and we call it a day.
Okay. So, num ms is not specified here.
M num ms right is not specified here at
all. So, is it specified in default
config?
does not so the number of atoms will be
the default which I believe is four
that's 8192
agents learning
rate 8 192 a jumps for the
be which is maybe just a little
high not really not with this batch size
it's
mini batch size is very low. This is
what we were using for other stuff
though. If we were to assume that it's
just harder,
then maybe this has to increase or
something. Possibly this just had to
increase. How are we uh we looking
on the baselines?
We don't get this like
smooth increase like we did with
Muan and very
odd. Well, hang on. Muan also did
have M had some tuning in the pram,
didn't it?
Okay. So we have atom beta 1, Adam beta
2 and an atom
epsilon. But these are a
default. Yeah, those are a
default except the
epsilon. Does mu um not muan does pspd
have an epsilon?
kind of with all of these we're getting
this
like
flattening. So this one I will give a
little more time because this is
potentially not stuck.
see mincom profit is higher actually
isn't
it? Oh yeah this is uh this is
unfortunate. So
like does
something then it undoes
something. It's at 50 mil.
Definitely something with
this this spike here.
But this is like such a more
consistent curve, you
know? It
like gets to
there. I mean this is like very
comparable. This early behavior here is
very
comparable, but then it just keeps
going. Whereas this
Yeah, this is fine. This is the same as
we have
rewards.
Two item
three. Yeah, these are all the same.
And then these train
params. Yeah, this is all the same as
well. Update
epoch. This gamma and lambda is really
suspicious.
Honestly, you know, I almost am
wondering if
um I was going to say I was wondering if
this was the culprit, but the thing
is we ran this before without this gamma
and still didn't work.
You can see right here as
well. I have this ridiculously low
learning
rate. I kind of just took all the params
as
is and I just ran it with where's the
optim? move
on. The only thing I did do is I took
these optimizer
params. Do you think I need to reduce
the learning
rate?
O004. This has a very small
learning
rate. That's probably why it's stretched
out so much as well.
O4 I think it's O3 or whatever for
um
Ah, hold on. It's not It's different
here. It's
0001. So, we could try this learning
rate potentially.
because this is a totally different
learning
rate from the other repo I was
using. Let's see if this other
experiment has gone
anywhere. Now, see, we're stuck here.
Fine. So, let's do uh let's try
00001?
01. So, this is
It could just be that, right? It could
just straight up be the uh the learning
rate.
It would be pretty sensitive to that
come to think of it because there's no
um there is a kneeling but it's such a
long time horizon that there may as well
not be a nailing
It would seem
like it would seem odd to me if that
were just it
though, right?
I mean, I
ran I ran this
with default hypers and then I ran this
with the matching hypers. It did
something very close.
Only thing I can think of
is I mean the learning rate is kind of
the most likely next thing. That is the
one parameter that if it's like way off
can just totally screw it
yet. Would that give you this type of
behavior though?
could. This is probably just like some
super
basic initial behavior, right?
Like dodging enemies or something.
Oh, I see something good
there.
Yep, I see something good here.
It looked like it made such a big
difference though.
I mean, look, it gets up to There.
min. Okay, you know this actually might
be something here. So, I think it is
literally just
sweep LR, sweep precondition LR, and I
think we'll be good. I just do
um like 500 mil or whatever. Let me get
that set up.
box? Okay. So, this is really obnoxious
that this works like this, but um we
will uh we'll fix this.
LR. Let me go get the ranges from uh
these guys.
parameters? Okay. Learning rate 1 e - 5
to 3 eus
3. Well, we have 1 eus 5 weight decay
not getting
used preconr
0001 to
1.5. Okay, that's crazy.
auto. I think we'll just do these for
now so we don't have to sweep a crazy
crazy number of parameters, you
know. This is
plenty. Do we leave the rewards
alone? It's basically one one negative
one with the clipping on, isn't
it? Yeah. Let's just remove these reward
params as well. Make it really easy to
compare everything.
And then this is going to be min
um min= 1.0 max equals
uh 20.0 now
believe and then was it total time
steps this is going to be
million everything
else is fixed
so these norms and
things honestly
batch. I kind of want to just yolo run
this.
right? Oh, holy, look at that. Mincom
prof. Yeah. Okay, this is this one
works. I think we can
uh we can even just mess with a couple
things before I do this.
50 524
288 batch size
32K? I want to do like a 16K on this
instead.
Okay. Yeah, look at
that. This is
solid. And this is now way outpacing
the previous
one. Okay, this optimizer worth
investing in a little bit. I think we're
going to do it this
way. I'm actually going to do a 192.
and delete all of these
It's all we have for training
here. There's this
thing. So, we're going to get rid of all
this
stuff. Uh, and the only thing we're
going to
put, we are going to keep this total
time steps in there. for the purposes of
uh learning rate
decay. But other than that, we're just
going to do
this and we're going to
see if this still learns uh roughly the
same. In which
case, the issue would have only been the
learning rate and nothing
else. That's what we're going to do now.
I'm going to just wait until this thing
um gets started and then I'm going to
end the stream cuz I'm going to go get
ready for bed and stuff and then I'm
just going to be checking on this over
the next like half hour or 40 minutes or
whatever. Um I'll monitor this and then
I'll start the sweep and hopefully we
will have some cool results by morning
and uh yeah, very exciting stuff. Very
exciting stuff indeed.
So, and if this works, then we'll have
basically optimizer stuff all set up. We
won't need m in a very good
spot. So, for the couple folks watching
at the moment,
uh if you're interested in following
more RL stuff, whether that's here to
see progress live or if you're
interested in getting involved,
puffer.ai, start the repo on GitHub to
help us out. really helps us out a ton.
And uh you can get involved in
development on the discord. Don't need
an RL background. You just need a
programming background and a desire to
learn. Some of our best contributors
came in with zero RL background. Other
than that, follow me on X for more RL
content and I will be